foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author and host the Dr John deloney show
on the Ramsey networks is my co-host
today we talk about your life and he
does as well including relationships and
boundaries and family and money and oh
we're going to do it all today and we're
going to talk about you right in front
of you the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five the
advice is free and some say it's worth
what you pay for it
triple eight eight two five five two two
five one week from yesterday
John's new book hits and that means
you've got just a couple of days to get
the buying a non-anxious life book
building building
I'd like to buy one buying the book
building a non-anxious life I'm trying
to get all these in one sentence here
it's running on and so there we go if
the book is coming out and if you buy it
on a pre-sale you get 75 dollars in free
bonus items including the e-book the
audiobook and one of John's talks uh
instant access to that smoke fire and
freedom that he did at one of our smart
conferences so jump in and get all of
that before the book actually comes out
next Tuesday you don't want to miss this
and um
we are seeing record numbers of these
books come out I was just in a marketing
meeting this morning here and it's uh
the number of you that are uh thinking
that he may have something to say
intelligent about this subject is
amazing because he does uh and the good
news about this it's not a psychology
book that uh will put you to sleep it's
actually on the Shelf where everyone can
reach it
yeah that was important for me to
um you know we've got a world now where
Stanford Medical School professors are
able just to crank out a podcast and
talk to each other some really high
level stuff some amazing insights into
the human mind and I often leave some of
those exchanges like thinking two things
wow it's amazing and all right what I
need to do right now right so and so
this book is I hand it to my my 13 year
old and said can you read this go
through it and he read it and he said
Dad I'll give you two stars
that's brutal um but it's designed for
everybody to be able to access it and
read it and then to more importantly
Implement a plan on how to make your
life better
because um anxiety is not the problem as
it turns out it's the alarm saying
there's a problem right and that problem
might be that your body is scan the
environment recognize you're lonely or
it might be that you have tied yourself
to a bank and they're telling you what
what to do tomorrow it might be that
your marriage is falling apart it might
be that
you've been trying to hold up the
universe all by yourself for a long long
time and there's several things that
will set your alarm off and we have an
entire world designed around the idea
that
the problems over there the problems
over there the problems over there and
I'm challenging people to go look in the
mirror and say what can I do right now
in my home or with my family or with my
community and start making these things
better right now yeah wow wow good stuff
folks check it out go to
ramsaysolutions.com and get it while
it's hot building a non-anxious life
twenty dollars it's a deal on a book
today I was looking at some data the
other day um our publishing guys were
bringing me the average hardback book
right now in America is 32 dollars
really yeah wow I didn't realize it just
slipped up we haven't raised our prices
enough and what we haven't our cost of
goods has gone up like 40 because
paper's gone way up yeah and uh and we
haven't raised our prices enough and
that's why I was in that meeting they're
trying to show me like you're we're
being doofuses and so we're going to fix
that but uh not right now right now you
can get this for twenty dollars so
that's pretty cool not 32. if this was
coming out of another publisher out of
New York it'd be 32 right now that's
that's what the deal is that's the
average price right now of a hardback
advice this book uh so check it out
phone number here is triple eight eight
two five five two two five Autumn is in
Denver hi Autumn welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey Dave and John how are you doing
today better than we deserve what's up
quite the conundrum we've been together
for free
for almost
we love each other very much and we'd
love to stay married but we feel like
we've tried everything when it comes to
managing our finances and we just can't
seem to agree the last step that we have
not tried is divorcing our finances so
I'm calling to ask if we should divorce
our finances
what would that get you
well let me give you a little bit more
background so we met at 21 and 24
respectively and had equal amounts of
student loan debt so we both had about
20 000 each so we decided the easiest
thing to do would be combine our
finances We Were Young we didn't have
any assets so it just made sense
so however we both come from very
different financial backgrounds and I
tend to be on the offense and he tends
to be on the defense and we both feel
like we're pulling each other and
dragging each other Along on a path
financially that we don't want to be on
he was pretty steeped in fire the
financial Independence retire early
movement and would prefer to spend less
and retire very early uh he's 39 and 36
first perspective he'd like to be
retired tomorrow if he could and I
prefer slower burn I'd rather make smart
decisions on investments and work harder
and earn more to achieve our goals and
Lead maybe a more comfortable lifestyle
so if he retired today what we do with
the rest of his life
all the things that he enjoys he'd
probably still make money but that's
always the question
he's built a life he doesn't enjoy
hmm
so let me just cut to it this ends in
Ash Autumn because y'all aren't dealing
with the core issue
the core issue is you're trying to live
two independent lives next to each other
in the same bed
and until you decide on we want our life
to look like this and we're going to
reverse engineer it starting today to
build it together
you're going to be like Jim Halpert and
Michael Scott you're going to be
co-managers of this thing and then
eventually it falls completely apart
well we've made it work for the 15 years
you know you absolutely have and I had a
1994 F-150 that I duct taped and glued
together and made work for a lot longer
than it should have
before you're saying there's not a
healthy way to divorce our finances and
stay married and I'm going to tell you
the further along you go
trying to pretend that what John's
saying is when you agree on your
spending
and saving goals you've agreed on your
life and your life and your values and
you're not in agreement on those things
you don't have a husband then you have a
roommate
we actually come up with a yearly budget
an annual budget we do a piano if you
want to do it go do it why don't you
call nasta we're not talking about
budgets we're talking about
your budget reflects unified values and
you don't have that
you have two independent people trying
to live independent lives and call it
something that it's not
okay so you haven't seen I mean I know
there's other people out there that have
have separated their finances and say it
was the best thing you know because oh
Lord Jesus they can knock your lights
out you called me and asked me they can
say everything that they want great
great what I'm telling you is this isn't
about money
hear me say that it's not about your
money it's not about your finances one
of the key things we learned in studying
ten thousand millionaires was none of
them said I drugged my spouse into this
Kicking and Screaming almost all of them
said I had a unified plan with my spouse
that caused us to be able to achieve
these goals you are dreaming this is not
going to happen it's bad relationally
it's bad mathematically it's bad
financially you're wrong don't do it
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today John in
quotes
that's not his real name in other words
from Louisville Kentucky not his real
place in quotes big secret call coming
in so John what's your question yes sir
um well about about two years ago I I
won one of those multi-state lottery
drawings with a group of co-workers and
uh I haven't told anyone uh besides my
wife and besides one sibling uh no one
knows and how much my question for you
um after taxes it was about 22 million
dollars
yeah how old are you it was a lot uh I'm
I'm edging up on uh about 50 years old
okay
okay so you haven't told anyone and I've
got some guesses but uh why
uh well the first thing I did when I
found out that a one was was research
and it said you know that you read all
those one in five people lose their uh
lottery winnings or go bankrupt within
10 years and one of the things they all
said was you tell too many people and
you get too many people at your door
asking for this that and the other thing
asking for handouts and expecting you to
pay for everything so my wife and I made
a conscious decision just to kind of
keep it under wraps and it's kind of we
we've kept keeping it under wraps
um we haven't even told our two teenage
children and now I know that sounds
strange
um but we just don't want them to grow
up uh to be waiters you know waiting for
us to die so they can get our money
you know
that's fantastic man yeah I love it it
has been evil rat poison lately I
probably hey I'm honestly uh I I I'll
spend the rest of the day imagining I'm
you because this sounds just like a fun
thing to think about
um I don't think I would tell my teenage
kids either no I'm okay with that no uh
they're I I want them to go figure out
what they want to do in life yeah and
yeah don't go be somebody and then and
then I'll let them know yeah I'm not
going to keep it from them forever but
like you know our parents and stuff we
haven't told any of them
um we had we had another incident about
a month after we won the lottery
um incident I don't want to call it my
wife's great uncle passed away shortly
thereafter and he didn't have any kids
and he was never married and he left
most of his inheritance to my wife and
her siblings so we've been able to use
that as like our cover story for when we
help people like I bought my mom a roof
I know really nice of me yeah but how
you know when she says how can you
afford this I just say oh scrape Uncle
Bob's money mom he want he wanted us to
do this yeah you know one of Bob's money
is at least 2xed now that's great yeah
oh and you can get it you can get it
have you got a decent car
you're going to love me Dave
um my house was paid off before I won
this yeah my wife and I really have no
desire to move good uh we had just paid
cash for two Toyotas before we uh before
we won this and we still have them we're
not looking to upgrade to anything
because they're perfectly fine cars so
okay we uh we we are you still working
I'm not are you still working I am still
I am still working yeah ridiculous I
know actually that's why I'm there
because I kind of like my job okay for
you I think you should I keep working
yeah yeah it's gonna make you a better
employee because you've gotten some
great investment advice
doing a good job good okay I like
everything you're doing
um and it's not it's not anyone else's
business
right that's what I hope and um I don't
think you're being like uh hermit in a
cave weird Unabomber weird or something
like that right I think you're just
being wise because what you have what
you've discerned is that some of the
people in your life could not handle
the equation
correct that is in a a very uh good
assumption on your part yeah and and so
you're doing them a favor by not putting
the strain on them including teenagers
so the only thing I can get close to is
is that um by the time my kids or
teenagers we had begun building
substantial wealth
we had recovered from the bankruptcy
Rachel was born so by the time Rachel's
16 it's you know 17 years since the
bankruptcy and we had you know I was a
multi-millionaire again okay we could
buy whatever car we wanted to buy we
could go on whatever vacation we wanted
to go on and it wouldn't affect us we
had good money okay but the kids had no
idea
and our kids had a double problem one is
their dad's in the spotlight
and everybody knows us right because
we're known in the community
um and talks about money no duh and if
they had that and they knew that we had
millions of dollars as a teenager I
don't think they could have processed it
so they did not know they knew we were
okay with money
they knew we lived the principles that
we teach and we made them live the
principles that we teach but they did
not know the X number of dollars was the
net worth right I only disclosed that to
them after they graduated from college
and I involved their spouses because by
that time two of them were married
and so I sat down with three of my kids
and two spouses five of them and we
started unpacking what our estate plan
looks like because they're adults at
that point and I told them up front I
said listen here's the deal we don't own
anything at our house we're people of
Faith so God owns a bunch of stuff he's
asked us to manage more than you know
and you're getting ready to know now and
you get to decide how you're going to
react to that are you going to react and
continue to be productive and generous
people or are you going to be in using
your words and I'll never forget it a
waiter right because if you're a waiter
you're not going to get access to any of
this we're going to take it away from
you because God wants you to be
productive he wants you to be whole he
wants you to be excellent in the
marketplace and he doesn't want us to
destroy you he wants you to have the
opportunity to serve a lot of people
with this wealth including my grandkids
to come and so as for me and my house we
serve the Lord and it's not our money
it's his we're managing it for him and
someday you will take over the
management but you will not become the
owner if you think you're the owner you
won't get to take over the management
and we that's how I unpacked it and then
when I unpacked it I was really pleased
that they weren't Freaks and they've
continued to live really good adult
lives and it's not ruined to them that
their dad has you know Dad and Mom have
a bunch of money that they manage you
know so uh all that so
I think you can start to build some
lessons into your teenagers now so that
in five years when you have that
conversation they're ready to shoulder
the weight of it
what do you think John all right yeah I
think you can live by example and I
think you have a pretty remarkable
opportunity to
take your kids out you know they're
having taken them out to dinner and
noticing a waiter that's struggling and
call the waiter over and be really kind
and then show your kids let's leave a
huge tip you want to do that and it
might be 100 bucks which is nothing of
of what you got in a bank but it's it's
going to be a million dollars to a
teenager right and you can slowly plant
the seeds of this is what generosity
looks like and when they it's kind of
like those movies you get to the end and
it like the sixth sense right and it
goes and you realize oh no I missed the
whole story and now I have the whole
story one day when you sit down and say
hey I'm uh you know that school that I
paid for and you know you and your wife
are about to buy a house
I'm going to pay for your mortgage and
here's actually what we're sitting on
and here's I like who I'm honored by who
you have become they're going to go oh
man I picked up all these lessons from
my mom and my dad they're also going to
learn that money isn't what makes it
isn't your identity your identity isn't
being a great dad it's a guy who still
got up and went to work it's a guy who
still kept the same Toyota that he'd
already paid with cash before like
you're doing everything so right it's so
healthy it's amazing you're healthy yeah
man yeah good for you if you were if you
were hiding this because you were
freaking and you were weird
I'll call you out on it you're wise
you're wise I think in this case
my sister called me the other day and
said what was your big splurge and my
answer was patio furniture I'm not a big
flashy guy uh well I I think you need to
increase gradually the enjoyment of this
money
you know not to not but not in the name
of the secret not in the name of the
spoken exposing the secret but you need
to increase the enjoyment and you need
to increase your generosity Factor
systematically you need to say all right
this year we're going to spend 400 000
on this or that create some neat
memories with your kids yeah do some
things intentionally with this without
just kind of rolling up an extra million
bucks into the budget this year you
don't have to do that although you've
got it but um yeah wow congratulations
brother it's a very good healthy view
yeah this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
over your head with student loans and
tired of getting calls from collection
agencies if private student loan debt is
taking away your financial piece and you
don't see any way out you need why refi
they're not a debt settlement company
and they're not connected to a bank why
refi refinances defaulted private
student loans that other places won't
touch and gives you a custom loan built
for you based on your ability to pay so
when you refinance your private student
loan debt with why refi you'll have a
payment you can afford with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lump sum payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
thanks for joining us America we're so
glad you're here Cole and Abby are with
us in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on
the debt free stage hey guys how are you
great happy to be here honored to have
you where do you live uh we live in
Franklin Wisconsin which is about 15
minutes south of Milwaukee Milwaukee
Wisconsin I love it very welcome to
Nashville thank you good to have you
guys and how much debt have you two paid
off we paid off 195
994 dollars and nine cents I love it
yeah how long did this take 34 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time we started at 134 and
ended at 173. very cool what do you all
do for a living I'm an occupational
therapist okay and I'm a production
manager at a cpg company okay very cool
good for you guys wow what kind of debt
was the 196 000. mostly student loans
yeah we had about 10 in credit cards
about 23 in car debt and there rest of
it almost 159 thousand dollars in
student loan debt wow yeah
how ironic that this Sunday student loan
payments start back but not for you
yes
we know a lot of people that didn't pay
any during the forbearance yeah I think
I can count on one hand including us the
number of people that continued to pay
and Hammer it out yeah we do too why did
you do that
because like are we sit around here
obviously we're talking shop it's like
just we've been trying to get people to
do what you did why did you do why did
you do it all your friends didn't do it
the government said we got you and you
knew they didn't like why did y'all keep
paying yeah we're in our 30s we're old
enough to know uh you can't wait on the
government uh but the other thing is
that we
wanted to set ourselves up for our
future right someone bought us Financial
Peace University for our wedding and we
sat down and talked about our wise our
baby girl we have now two months three
years ago when we started you know she
wasn't in the picture but we knew one
day she would and we didn't want to try
to be buying a house and buying cars
with cash and funding her College while
having the student loan debt hang over
our head and me the nerd I did the math
with the interest before the forbearance
it would have been a thousand dollars a
month for 21 years for us to pay off the
student loan debt and that's not
something either of us wanted to sign up
for wow yeah
so how long you all been married three
years this past June okay so you've been
doing this whole time you've been
married yeah we got married in June and
then because of covid we had like our
reception in September so it was in that
uh September reception we've already
been married for four months when we got
a Financial Peace University okay so
somebody gave you that as a gift for
your wedding yeah and then you you went
to the class yeah it was virtual right
yeah it's cold yeah but yes we did the
class and
um we I've been listening to you for
years before that and we were Dave ish
and this is how dumb I was Dave I
thought that's a really good plan for
other people yeah not for us and even
going into the class we thought well
maybe we'll do it maybe we won't after
the first lesson or two we were all in
we figured if we're gonna do it we got
to do it all the way 34 months later
here we are we're on to three and we're
done with three now we're out of three B
so we're excited for what's next even
taking it virtually it sucked you into
the Vortex oh yes it did I love it well
we're honored man congratulations you
guys what did your friends say when you
told them you're paying on your loans
and they they roll their eyes at you
they give it to you pretty good oh yeah
um why would you do that the same thing
with the credit cards um what about the
miles what about the points um you can
use the money for other things we just I
don't know we were just together in it
the whole way and that was a surprising
piece actually is how many people gave
us shellac for it
um for having this beer plan yeah did
that give you energy like I'll show you
yeah I heard so many times people say oh
me and my wife are dead free well except
for our cars you always have a car
payment and we looked at him and said
then you're not debt free we've heard
you'll always have a student loan and I
look at them and say you will always
have a student loan we will not always
have a student loan so it's very
motivating yeah and now you get to do
Toby Keith How You Like Me Now that's
right that's right I like it yeah you
should throw a party on October 1st just
stay like I'll I'll get everybody dinner
because I know it's gonna be a hard hard
night for me that's right we got no
payment so we can afford having a
celebration you guys are having a
funeral is that uh we're hating on you
that's right I love it yeah just rub a
little salt in the winter that'd be
great yeah for you guys man I'm so proud
of you thank you so who was cheering you
on
who were your cheerleaders a lot of our
family obviously my mother's side of the
family was the one who gifted us FPU so
they were huge in that
um some of our friends actually
introduced us to you as well and kind of
kept along with us on the journey that's
cool yeah okay
um yeah that's about it our good friends
uh Brittany and Sam I want to give them
a shout out because before we did this
we'd always go out on the town going out
to eat spending lots of money we told
them hey we're gonna do this FPU thing
so we're not going out to eat anymore
and they said that's great you guys just
come on over here we'll grill out we'll
do things at the house that are free
they were very very supportive I like
that that's a cool cool that's a cool
group of friends right there yes yeah
and actually have a better time doing
that than you do going to arrest oh yes
yeah we had more yeah more fun yeah yeah
way to go gosh thank you so proud of
y'all well well done well done now what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt you pay off 196
000 in 34 months it's not a theory you
freaking did it everyone can do it on
paper right it's a lot harder to doing
reality yeah I always say the hardest
part is starting the first two three
months when you're learning to budget
and at the end of the month you have
this money it's true it stinks to send
it off to navient or Toyota financial
whoever but for us after those first two
three four months it became such a
routine and such a habit it honestly
went by really quick just because we
were like a well-oiled machine once we
got the monthly routine of budgeting and
paying off it became exciting actually
how much money are we gonna pay off how
much how much are we going to be able to
fill in on our debt turns into a game
it's a mental game like where else can
we cut yeah where else can we increase
income yeah yeah and every month we're
like yeah we're 150 bucks under budget
exciting yeah
y'all are almost too unified did y'all
ever have a fight we don't fight about
money no no no this um we were on the
same page pretty much before FPU but
this really solidified not just money
but just all aspects of our marriage I
think yeah yeah what was the hardest
part
I think getting started like Cole said
yeah
um but I also was surprised I think I
was disappointed by people's reactions
when we would tell them that we were
doing this saying no telling each other
no for things was hard as well but just
the reactions that we would get this was
such like an exciting thing for us to
start on and so many people were
doubtful or like that's not gonna last
yeah
um so that was kind of hard to kind of
hear that from people well you kind of
figure out who your friends are yes and
I was like okay you are Eeyore
oh it's bad it's so bad you're never
gonna make it you're always gonna have a
car oh now I know who Eeyore is yeah
that's it so yeah good for you guys very
very well done hey we've got the live
and give bundle for you that's the box
that has all the goodies in it for you
to give away and live baby steps
Millionaire's book which is your next
step for sure The Total Money Makeover
book to give away maybe one of those
doubters or maybe one that needs to get
moving same thing Financial Peace
University membership it for you to give
away and all that's our gift to you to
say thanks for coming down all right are
we putting a little baby in
she's ko'd right now but we can no you
don't have to I'm just that's a sacred
moment let it let it ride let it rise
she's chill I'm good I don't care I just
didn't want you to I don't want to lose
you the opportunity here she comes we'll
just believe her in her little seat here
all right that's perfect yeah what's her
name Presley Presley all right Presley
you have no idea that your parents are
heroes they have changed your family
tree little girl yeah that's how old
Rachel was when I filed bankruptcy so
wow you guys are in a great place I'm so
proud of y'all congratulations thank you
very good all right Cole and Abby
Presley hold your little ears all right
now 196 000 paid off in 34 months making
134 to 173 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I don't even think Presley woke up
that's pretty good I mean I think she's
used to her dad being that intense
around the house so it's all right it's
all good he's yelling at football too
there you go he's more of a spreadsheet
Yeller but it's cool
[Laughter]
it works man I'll tell you what if the
first 34 months of your marriage you can
learn to
uh align yourselves together on goals
you set yourselves up to fight any
battle to win any game that you run into
after that don't you well it reminds us
of that call we took earlier this is
what we were talking about this is
exactly we're talking about if you
decide where you're going getting there
becomes just a it's a totally different
trajectory yep you're not riding side by
side you're riding in the same car going
to the same place building the same life
together this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation in
prayer is hallow how hello is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you three months free to get
started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and how
I flick you can tailor the content
towards your faith tradition if you
don't have a faith tradition this is a
great place to learn more about it from
scripture readings and prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hallow.com Ramsay today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
Dr chandeloni Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and host of the
Dr John deloney show is my co-host today
Travis is with us in Philadelphia hi
Travis welcome to the Ramsay show
hello Dave how are you doing better than
I deserve what's up
uh Davis is in fact I've been praying
and this is actually speaking to you
um what's going on with my life around
that day does that mean more like rap
Crossroad uh we have two small children
we've been trying to do the baby steps
for almost eight months now it's not
working we're not we're not getting past
baby step one there's always some kind
of emergency things are happening that
and we're just not getting there
um but we the crossroads we're at right
now is that uh I did get a we have a lot
of debt you have about 40 000 in auto
loans
um about ten thousand student debt and
students on that and 20 000 like credit
cards
I haven't offered to get a new job
that's going to pay I pay I make about
37 000 now I got a job offer about like
54 000. it's not the best job in the
world just to work in a correctional
officer something I'm not too fond of
but I'll do it uh for the money to get
out of debt but also we have a lot of
equity in our home uh home is worth
about maybe upwards about uh 380 000 we
have about 230 000 left on the mortgage
and we can sell and we can get that
Equity
oh you oh 230 and it's worth 280. 380.
no so 380 380. oh okay yeah about 380 uh
the real estate agent said we should go
uh the five percent price at like 410
because things are selling pretty fast
in my area so so you've got 100 150
000 you might have coming to you if you
did that
if we did that correct and where would
you live
I'm in Pennsylvania now we moved to I
have a job offer in November for the
city of Dallas
um for the police department in Dallas
and um that's that's where we moved to
we moved to Dallas we have a good friend
of mine that lives out there
he's been working out there for about a
year now and he's been trying to get me
to come out there and so we can move to
so we have a solid
written job offer not a vague promise
from a friend
no I I
um I have a solid written job offer in
November yeah I will start the academy
for the police department out there I
got it and
um okay so you are planning on moving
anyway
why would you ask me if you should sell
your house
of course you're going to sell your
house you're moving to Dallas
right but the reason why I say that
because um like I said I have two small
children I'm just out of Crossroads I
don't know if
that's the best you know I don't know
how safe Dallas is I don't have a friend
who said it it's pretty good but
you know how safe Dallas is compared to
Philadelphia
well I'm not I'm not actually in Philly
I'm about 90 minutes away from it uh in
the Poconos let me say it this way my
dad was a homicide detective A Beat cop
and then a Thomas a detective for uh
almost two decades in Houston and he
raised me and my two siblings
and I wouldn't trade my childhood for
anything
okay okay
if you continue to always look over the
edge what if what if what if what if
in a weird way you're going to create
those scenarios in your life
all right what would you pay what would
you be paid if you went to Dallas
um starting salary for also out there is
about 60 66 000. that's the solid offer
they gave you in writing
correct and then you get out of the
academy and then what does it go to
that that I don't know but I know going
into the academy about 66. okay okay so
you're almost gonna double your income
you're going to sell your house move to
Dallas and be debt free and you've got
no state income tax
yeah this is kind of a no-brainer you'll
have no debt you need to put the house
on the market and go to Dallas and you
rent for a year in Dallas figure out
what's the best place for schools and
for that's going to fit your family's
lifestyle and what y'all are comfortable
with and then you're gonna put an offer
on a house yeah
easy right it makes sense uh I was just
afraid of your own just moved to a
bigger city uh the crime
the you know just just everything just
would be the best hey let me tell you
something turn the news off
you literally have a friend on the
ground who lives there and works there
and he says I love my friend I love you
enough you should come join me and
you're like I don't know because I
watched your friend wouldn't tell you
come down here and get your children
killed yeah
you're right you're right so move to
Dallas Dallas is not a crime-ridden city
it has crime every city has crime but
it's not crime ridden it's not infested
or something I don't this isn't it Lodge
and you want to be a cop I was gonna say
I mean this is kind of part of part of
your uh there's a little crime you
wouldn't need a job or part of the
academy is going to be pushing you real
hard to see risk ahead
and go anywhere because that's what
you're that's what police officers do
and the rest of us are running out go
anywhere they go in yeah and so you're
gonna have to you're gonna have to wash
that part out of you man because this is
the job okay so the last thing I want
you to do though is
when you clean all this up you you guys
have to get on a budget and you have to
quit freaking spending money you don't
have to buy cars you can't afford in the
future and on these stupid but credit
cards
so you all have not been living on less
than you make you bought cars you
couldn't afford you bought other crap
you couldn't afford that's how these
credit cards got there so when you clean
all this up if you make 66 and you go to
spending 75 and you go upgrade your
dadgum cars and go back in debt well
then I'm gonna come kick your butt all
right no you're not doing that all right
you're gonna live on less than you make
you're gonna clean this mess up this is
your one time good time reset
you don't get to do these resets very
often
so take advantage of it dude jump online
and get every dollar the budgeting out
and you and your wife start budgeting
get the house on the market finds go to
ramsaysolutions and.com and get get one
of the real estate agents that are
Ramsay trusted and get your house on the
market dad gum man it's October you've
got to move in a month
get your butt and get it let's go let's
go let's go game on game on let's you
house ought to be on the market this
weekend
you need to you need to go it's time and
you're gonna be one of those guys that's
like well I need to clean it I need to
make sure listen loading up the truck
and heading to Beverly baby let's go
sell the house sell the house we're
going let's go the gutters are how the
gutters are sell the house that's it you
know get out there and clean it up this
weekend get those kids and gear trim the
bushes mulch them let's go game on game
on game on I'm hearing this more and
more I hear this on my show with some
regularity and I think it's important to
Just note
there's so many places to get
information these days that it does
overwhelm the Mind well and here's the
problem
half of what is on the Internet it's
garbage is not even true 75 it's not
real it's not true I pulled up a website
yesterday with Ken and on there uh
that's got Dave Ramsey's exotic car
collection and my picture and all of the
cars that I own only I don't own any of
them
they're fabulous cars I wished I did and
I own a few nice cars that have been
cool if you put them on there but no
he's got all this wonderful vehicles on
there that I don't own
that website does not exist for me Dave
I'm just like Abraham Lincoln said
everything on the internet is true I
mean come on you know oh my gosh people
yeah you just got it you got to quit
just feeding garbage into your brain and
then because you know well I read an
article that said John deloney or Dave
Ramsey was this or that well
you can write an article on anything it
doesn't make it true people just make up
crap well that's why you know because
they're mad or their feelings are hurt
to have incredible trustworthy men and
women in your life that you can call and
say hey is this a good deal like man
you're gonna love this job it's gonna be
great for you and your family move on
down here yeah then
that guy doing that for Travis is a
thousand out of a thousand Travis
reading about something on the internet
right is a thousand out of a thousand
the other tracks you know there's crime
in Dallas well no of course I mean you
know it's everywhere but um at least in
Dallas there's no anyway yeah it's
there's yeah do it uh Texas yeah do it
make Texas great again yeah let's go
game on
there's so many places I could go with
that in a minute and a half and I'm not
going to all right please don't please
don't triple eight eight two five five
two two five I should increase the hate
level around you I don't do that I think
I think we are good you think we gotta
thank you enough I think it is as high
as it needs to be okay
I think we should increase the love okay
let's increase the love okay well that
that's harder it is harder it is harder
sell your house man let's go Travis
Travis get that house on the market get
moved send us a photo of you in your
uniform when you get out of the academy
we'll be rooting for you yeah you're on
our team man we love you keep it up get
after it get after it get after it that
puts this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books thank you
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
thanks for joining us America we're glad
you're here open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host the Dr John
deloney show on the Ramsey networks is
my co-host today is new build new life
building a not new life his new book
building a non-anxious life comes out in
under one week this coming Tuesday if
you want to get a great deal on it it's
only twenty dollars right now and it
includes on pre-sale if you do it before
Tuesday seventy five dollars worth of
extra goodies so go check it out the
book will help you work through and deal
with properly the preparation so when
anxiety comes with the six daily choices
you've made not if but when it comes you
will know how to deal with it so pick it
up at ramseysolutions.com get started
Lynn is I'm going to start this hour off
in Philadelphia hi Lynn welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey guys it's such an honor to speak to
you thanks for taking my call sure
what's up uh I actually have a two-part
question
um not sure if I can get to both of them
but my first question
um is really starting to something's
really starting to get to me it's
affecting my family and my marriage
um my husband is taking responsibility
um for his parents my in-laws finances
he's has created them a budget he's
paying their bills for them he's going
as far as controlling their expenses
uh I'm not sure this is healthy and it's
causing friction is he using their money
or your money
he's using their money okay so it's not
costing you anything how old are they
how old are they
okay and why is this not healthy do they
need help
um let's just say that them doing it on
their own they haven't been doing very
well themselves
um and I think my husband is just afraid
of
you know them overspending and
yeah but you said that you said this is
not healthy and it's driving you crazy
so why is it not helping me crazy why is
it not healthy and why is it driving you
crazy
I don't think it's healthy because he's
taking over and doing it himself
um we don't agree with it so he's
causing friction with us
um and
it's not that they're not able to do it
it's kind of like he wants to do it for
them because he thinks he'll do it
better could it be that he knows for 79
years I've watched my parents fail at
this and they're getting really close to
falling off a financial cliff that as my
as their son I'm gonna feel some sort of
obligation to help out with and I can I
can stop them from driving off the edge
is it that
it is uh 100 that which I'm okay with
but he's kind of gone
a little too far not just giving them
advice but just basically there's
something else deeper why don't you do
you not like them
I love them they are my second parents I
lost my parents at a young age when we
just uh we've been married for 25 years
so they've become my second parents
um so what's what's the thorn on your
side on this
you know I think it's that
I I think you know partly it's that they
can't do it themselves okay so are you
mad at them or him for that
I think I'm mad at them okay so let's
make sure the anger's in the right
direction all right and
and I
probably part of me is just kind of
bummed that the time that we should be
spending together on our own finances is
kind of going toward them all right
that's a totally different conversation
one of those conversations gets wrapped
up in your and you are pressing your
husband up against a wall saying it's
mere them
and he's looking and saying I love you
both I dedicated my life to you I said I
do to you you're my wife and I'm
watching my parents sliding off the edge
the real question you're asking is I'm
really frustrated that two grown people
who I love haven't and won't and can't
seem to figure out how to take care of
their money and my husband is the kind
of man who steps in that Gap
but I don't want that to come at the
expense of our marriage and our
relationship and our time together
planning for our future
and so husband can we spend time
together focusing on our finances that's
separate then you shouldn't be doing
that with them you see what I'm saying I
do one of those makes him have to wall
up and pick and the other says is makes
calls is a challenge are you gonna be
are you going to be um my partner in
this deal and are you going to continue
to dream with me on what our house looks
like
so you voice to him that you're
frustrated
I have he knows um he knows I'm not a
fan of the whole situation so I let me
tell you what I think I heard you say
and if I was wrong tell me okay
I think I heard you say I'm frustrated
because these two grown-ups won't be
grown-ups I love them but I hate
irresponsibility and I hate the way that
they are just so lame when they don't
have to be
and that aggravates me and I'm also
aggravated because you're taking time
away from us
that I really need to have some things
done over here on our finances before
you go over there
uh you pretty much nailed it okay
why don't you say that back to him that
way
I I think that's a really good idea and
can I throw one twist in there that's
gonna be hard for you to say
sure
can you say I am proud that you're the
kind of
man that um sees his mom and dad in need
and however frustrating it is you're
willing to step in that Gap
yes that's super important yeah I do
agree you are proud of his character you
just you just hate it that they're being
so lame-o
oh yeah I kind of agree with you but
yeah it's super frustrating aggravated
at both of them they're perfectly
able-bodied and able-minded to do this
and they're just too trifling to do it
right
you're yeah yeah and that aggravates
that that aggravates people that are
responsible right right and you know
that that's I agree with your
aggravation
um I just don't think that uh your
aggravation is going to fix it
because you're not you're being
aggravated it's not going to make them
suddenly responsible
and so they're either going to run in
the ditch as John said or over the edge
as John said
um or your husband's probably going to
do what he's doing
because you know they may have seven
years they might have ten and
um you know and they're either going to
be a burden to you all financially
because they completely wreck the rest
of their lives here or your husband's
gonna do this because they the chances
are these people changing their habits
the old dog new tricks at this stage
probably pretty low is that fair
yeah and can he go too far can he say
hey I'm going to help you all not fall
off the edge and suddenly become their
mommy and daddy Alder one yes yeah and
it's okay to call on that call him out
on that yeah but yeah
sounds like you got a good man stuck in
a weird situation and it's frustrating
frustrating let's work towards this you
have a valid frustration with their
irresponsibility
but not a good solution
he's got a better solution this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personalities my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Lauren is in Chicago hey Lauren welcome
to the Ramsay show
hi thank you for all the work you guys
do for um American people I have been
listening for a couple months
um to a lot of the different shows and
my husband and I I'm learning a little
and we are okay we've made um you know
some good decisions and some bad
decisions based on the Ramsey way but
right now
we're looking at wanting to pay our
house off we don't have any other debt
and how do people do that like is it
okay to just set aside the money and
then pay it off in one month some or
what is what's the Ramsay way is our
recommendation or a book
now I don't take a book it's just early
and often every month send as much
towards the house payment as you can
send
and what happens is it lowers your
balance
so the next month more of your regular
payment will go towards principal
then and then it would have if you
hadn't let's say you sent ten thousand
dollars okay
well you no longer have to pay interest
on that ten thousand dollars so the end
the monthly interest on that ten
thousand dollars less will be low I mean
on the balance will be lower
than uh than it was by ten thousand
dollars you follow me
I do
I've learned and understand however my
husband's more comfortable with having a
lump sum available just in case
um anything happens with the house any
emergency yeah before you start paying
off do you have an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
um we have an emergency we have about
um shaved and then the heavens okay your
husband's theory is ludicrous what do
you what does he expected what kind of
what do you think is going to happen
Armageddon
your cash won't be good yes there will
not be ATMs during Armageddon
what do you owe on your home
uh we just I'm so grateful to God we uh
we we lived in like a thousand how much
do you own your home or
oh six uh 633 I'm sorry 633 well what I
would do if I woke up in your shoes is I
would take three to six months of
expenses given that your husband likes
to have a little bit more let's say six
months of what's your household income
250. okay all right so let's be super
generous okay set a hundred thousand
aside
that's more than you need that's more
than six months okay and call that your
emergency fund it's a ridiculous
emergency fund but 700 000 everything
above a hundred thousand is cray cray it
needs to be going on the house
it's just you're not going to have a
hundred thousand dollar emergencies
can I ask another dumb question no not
dumb these are dumb questions these are
great questions do you ever recommended
if South Investments do you ever
recommend taking those out and putting
it towards the house always no always
unless they're in return unless they're
in retirement account
okay you wanna know why single stock
sell them you want to know why
why because when we studied the largest
study of millionaires ever done in North
America over ten thousand of them
we never found them saying we invested
instead of paying off our home and
that's how we became millionaires none
of them say that
almost all of them follow the model of a
steady reasonable amount of investing
like in their retirement accounts then
paid off the home and then increased
their investing when the home was paid
off and so the typical person with say a
million and a half dollar net worth
their first one and a half million
dollars of net worth had a five or six
hundred thousand dollar paid for home
and about a million dollars in their
401k
but the number of them that said oh we
never pay off our house instead we
invested more and more and more and kept
the house debt was almost zero it was
less than 10 percent
going so the data says that the best and
the fastest way to build wealth is get
the house paid off while steadily
investing about 15 percent of your
income above an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses so if you guys
making 250 have squirreled over in an
investment a half million dollars
I'm going to tell you get this house
paid off next 12 months
and take that money in there now not
taking out 401K money but I'm talking
about you've just gotta you know you've
got a brokerage account of some kind
over here with a half million dollars
sitting in it take that and the 60 above
the hundred and throw it at the thing
let's get this house paid off because I
got to tell you if I ever get your
husband to pay off his house
he will think he's a genius and he'll
never ever ever go back in debt on that
house well and I want to make sure we
point we we touch on this this he's
solving for safety and right now safety
for him is having a bunch of cash and
and non-retirement investment that's
right and he's hedging his safety
against all these other things and he's
got this big elephant sitting in his
living room and you who We've joked
about this off air before no one has
ever called the show and said man I'm
really mad at y'all because I paid my
house off six months later Dave Ramsey
told me to pay my house off I wish I had
my mortgage back I love my mortgage you
say it all the time you can always go
take out a mortgage six months from now
if you don't like it right if you don't
like having a paid for a house but you
think you're you think you're solving
for safety with all these
extracurricular activities try sleeping
in a house that you owe nobody anything
for
that's a level of safety that you didn't
know your body could feel until you go
do it yeah I'm telling you when you have
let's just talk about safety okay when
we have a fouchy quarantine and the
whole freaking Place shuts down and your
house is paid for
it feels a whole lot different inside
your physical body than having the same
amount of your mortgage in a mutual fund
because there's a part of your brain
that's been there for eternity that says
you're going to lose your house your
kids are gonna be on the street yeah
because they're 100 of foreclosures
happen on a house with a mortgage that's
right versus being real frustrated right
being annoyed and frustrated that's
different than I can't breathe right you
know I mean I had uh we had business
stress we had relational stress uh
because of disagreements but David
Sharon Roy's gonna be okay over the
covid you know we found out who our
friends were who were all worried about
little kovitz jumping on people and all
the stuff we did we dealt with all that
stuff but we didn't deal
during the factory quarantine with the
threat of foreclosure right that's not
in there and so when you're solving for
safety that was a good phrase I like
that phrase you know you you probably
need to really correctly Define safety
right and get the elephant out of your
dead gum living room which is the living
room by the way yeah ironically
it's in the way we said it before we had
John with two phds to help us understand
it was if your house is paid for take
your shoes off walk through the backyard
the grass feels different
you breathe different and you work you
won't work at a toxic Place anymore
because you have to you're not stuck
anymore folks and so the solving for
this is
you know when I first started teaching
this stuff I thought well if you got rid
of a house payment you invested a house
payment you can turn that money into a
million dollars pretty quick and that's
the math part the financial part but
there's an emotional part A Spiritual
part A relational part a medical health
a mental health part I you know someday
it'll be done I I don't know that I'll
ever get around to doing it but a study
of the medical condition and the life
quality of life and longevity of Life of
people who are debt free versus those
that aren't they're quietly starting to
to leak out into the world where people
are doing mental health and emotional
health and debt and starting to use that
correlative data it's it's it's pretty
frightening yeah I've talked to some
doctoral students they're interested in
doing their dissertations on
student loans and people with debt
versus the mental health of those who
don't owe anybody anything no and if you
think about this think about think of
all of us
um
um have had the moment in our career
when we think oh man I gotta go have a
hard conversation with my boss I may not
survive this one
imagine your wife or your husband can
put your face in their hands and look at
you and say hey we're gonna be okay
we're gonna plenty of money go tell the
children playing money we got no house
payment go tell the truth go be you and
we don't have any house payments man
like that's a different conversation
there we go this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45 five percent off that's
blinds.com rules and restrictions May
apply
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today Spencer
and Jordan are with us in the Ramsey
Solutions headquarters Lobby on the
debt-free stage hey guys how are you
pretty good welcome where do you all
live
Terre Haute Indiana I love it very good
good to have you all right how much data
have you two paid we paid off 150 000 we
sold our house wow how long did all this
take uh through well selling the house
took a couple months but uh we lived in
the house three and a half years and we
downsized from 3 000 square foot to
about 1200 with the family of five so
whoa hey no mortgage payment so it's uh
worth it hardcore wow so y'all renting
now no we bought it with cash for what
we made from our other house so yep oh
so you bought a house so you don't have
a mortgage no mortgage
you sold the house bought another house
with the equity no mortgage of any kind
how old are you two I am 31 32. but in
order to do this you moved into a tiny
little place yes sir and I no regrets
okay and you don't have to be there
forever it's a step yes okay and you're
32 years old and what's this house worth
that you're living in uh 130 135 okay
I'd say we we actually just cash flow to
remodel on it too so
um okay so it's pretty nice okay and we
can live there for a few years and then
move up easy easy easy and uh so okay
again so this whole experiences really
did gone down pretty quick right yes sir
but uh we actually uh grew up in in you
know Ramsey
um
uh foundations right we have family
members who have followed the baby steps
and passed that on to us
um Jordan actually has a great story
with The Total Money Makeover yeah when
I was a junior in high school my parents
saw that I was not great with money and
they were like we'll pay you twenty
dollars to read The Total Money Makeover
so a great twenty dollars
um it did not stick until I got married
so not a great twenty dollars but no no
it was spent probably the next day but I
inherited 13 when we got married
yep part of that twenty dollars and uh
yeah big shout out to my mom who's uh
followed Dave Ramsey for a long time in
the steps and all the way through
college we were able to to kind of cash
flow so this this all this stuff was
around in your childhood your kind of
financial peace babies in a sense yes
sir okay all right now but once you
decided okay we got this big house we
could sell it we could buy another house
you did all that within a matter of
months yep so really like four months or
something to be that free once you make
the call right yes sir would you have
other debt to pay off too no we paid off
my student loans
um when was it a few years ago and we
had a two and a half three year gap of
no loans no no being debt free and then
we bought the house 2019 sold it uh
earlier this spring so so what lit y'all
up what what said like hey let's leave
this big nice house where everyone's got
their own bathroom and room and let's
get out of this mess you know we just it
was a it was it was a great it was a big
beautiful house and we just were like
you know what we want to change and we
knew that that wasn't our forever home
um so we were like why are we paying
this big mortgage when we could downsize
be completely debt free and then save
for what will be our forever home
way to go you guys very cool what's your
household income right now it's around
110. what do you all do for a living
be kids
uh currently in the Air National Guard
working in I.T and then my civilian jobs
in it as well so wow good for you good
career field they're both awesome yeah
yeah way to go guys you're Heroes okay
congratulations
um to all of the young parents out there
who say there's no possible way you
could have three beautiful rambunctious
little ones uh was his oldest one what
six seven he's nine nine okay so you got
nine and seven and five yep
you can't possibly have a family of five
and a 1200 square foot house oh it's
awesome how do you make it work bonding
no it's uh it's a lot of fun yeah the
boys share bedroom and Remy our daughter
she has her own room and honestly it's
probably been a lot harder for them than
it has for us it's a lot less cleaning a
lot less maintaining for us and I think
they're getting used to it a lot of
times Outdoors but we haven't gone
through winter yet so we'll see through
the deciding factor January February
range I had one sibling I grew up in 1
000 square foot home yeah
so
um
and um yeah wow yeah it's amazing when
you look back I went over there and
visited it not long ago it kind of
shrunk yeah that's uh it's like going
back to your Elementary School at shrunk
yes yes but I think you guys are going
to be great I'm so proud of y'all yeah
it's not a long-term play really it's a
short-term play yep it's a it's a
sacrifice and we knew it when we when we
bought the house and we actually
um you think about a thousand bucks a
month going to the bank it's like you
know what could we be doing with this
and knowing that we were going to
um buy a forever home from a family
member
um in the future
um you know we can be saving that and
you know treat this house as a rental
for the kids yeah as they go after
school yeah that'd be great but now it's
a and with the homeschool stuff so in
your own case you made this from one
Fell Swoop you grew up with some of
these things around you what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
because your story is different
um for me it would just be the budgeting
was the hardest part for us I think was
just sitting down and making a budget
and I feel like it's gotten even harder
now that we are debt free is sitting
down and still maintaining that budget
but I think that that's what I tell
people is get on the same page sit down
write a budget do what's best for your
family yeah the discipline and the
um the reminder that it's God's money
right be a good Steward of it and the
lesson for the kids and all the way
going through the house selling in the
house buying process with them by our
sides a lot of
um well you took a step back so I I
think looking at you from the outside
looking in I think your secret was
contentment yeah
you're willing to be content with that
as a step I'm going to live like no one
else so later I can live and give like
no one else it being kind of cultural
and knowing that it's
um just it's God's will yeah doing it so
we often tell people don't sell your
house to get out of debt because you
don't you don't go through you don't
learn the lessons but y'all y'all were
debt free for three years before you sat
down and said let's go do something
radical yep yeah very well done good job
you guys I'm pretty cool all right bring
the kiddos up let's hear their names and
ages have they been practicing any
debt-free screams just since we've been
here Mrs Grayson he is nine Milan who's
seven and Remington who is five go
Remington all right I think Remington's
in charge any type of family has their
kids come up and they all just stand in
a straight line and they're respectful
and kind that's great that's very cool
makes me want to be better at being a
parent
I love it it's very good you guys hey
we've got The Total Money Makeover book
for you the baby steps millionaires book
that's the next chapter in your story
for you and the Financial Peace
University membership you can live some
of that you can give some of that thanks
for coming for down here from Terre
Haute and sharing your inspiring story
and your beautiful family you guys are
amazing way to go Heroes Your Heroes you
took control those little babies right
there their whole lives are changed
because their mom and dad are grown-ups
very well done Spencer Jordan Grayson
Milan Remy I gotta love it from Terre
Haute 150 000 paid off in about four
months sold their home moved into a
smaller one so they had it all paid off
making 110. count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
wow wow
fabulous
in 1963 the average family in America
had a 1 000 square foot one level home
one car
that was the average family in America
today the average family in America has
2.5 cars and 2 900 square feet you can
tell you something wild about that
besides just the cost
um
one of my plans to go down a nerd rabbit
hole is there's some quiet conversations
about
families over the last you know
centuries and thousands of years have
grown up together you could hear each
other breathe you could see each other
and that one of the causes of anxiety
may be that everybody from you get into
the bassinet you get your own room and
you're on the other side of the house
you're upstairs someone's downstairs and
you're all on screen everybody's alone
and everybody's on screens and there's
something about bringing the family back
together that's that's sounds kind of
neat I don't know the data on it kind of
regulates but it's interesting it's
interesting thought regulates their
bodies overnight we stuck everybody in
their own room on the other side of the
house and I don't know that we're
designed for that it's an interesting
thing to think about this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality open
phone's a triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money Joe Is
With Us in Springfield Hey Joe welcome
to the Ramsay show
Dave thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
to you often on the last couple years it
has a lot of things haven't soaked in
but the other day you said that nobody's
shown a new truck unless they have a net
worth of a million in their debt-free
well I bought a new one earlier this
year and so my question number one is
should I sell that truck and downgrade
get something a little bit more
economical
so that I can pay it off
how much do you owe
uh 43 no 42 and some change so 43.
what's your household income
220 210 and you don't have any money
no I have uh I have about 40 in the bank
right now
mm-hmm how long you been making that
kind of money
oh
years you're making good money why do
you not have any
well
my wife kind of lived YOLO I kind of
live like hey we might live to be 500.
and it's just it's been 15 years it's
just kind of we've sat down we put
budgets together and it just did it
doesn't stick on one end and it does on
one and
I've just kind of learned to compromise
to keep the marriage happy
and uh but the marriage isn't happy man
I can hear it on you
it's frustrating I mean I love her to
death wouldn't trade her for nothing but
it's frustrating you know when you have
a divided house
um you know like I hate Christmas I
um you know we spend four thousand
dollars every year in Christmas and it's
to people and friends and and every year
we argue about it and it just gets me
where I just hate Christmas you know
because I know we're just gonna fall
bunch of money and we shouldn't and we
don't have to because yeah you know you
just you move on you know you can either
dwell on it or you can just move on and
then and then you borrowed 40 000 on a
truck yeah
yes well I I'm a sales guy so I have to
have a truck that's less than three
years old and so many miles I get paid
850 a month for my truck allowance
whether you have a car payment or not
that's right and that's where I would
rather talk to 850 and throw it on the
house we're in a great situation on the
house house is worth about six six and a
quarter we're down to about 270 on it
okay uh
the truck the truck needs to be paid off
for it needs to be sold but it's 10
percent of your problem
okay the problem that's screaming at me
in this conversation is you make way too
much money to be this broke
I agree and you guys are really going to
sit down and address that
you're just you're you're just wait
there's a quarter no you haven't you
this is not fixed but what do you do
well I think you if you can't if you and
your wife can't sit down and dream about
a future that you're willing to control
yourselves for
because you're not controlling yourself
you have no self-control in your
household and if you the two of you
can't find a house a dream then in high
definition that the two of you can agree
to that is worth working towards
together and worth not spending
everything we make to cause it to happen
then you do need to sit down with a
marriage counselor if that's the case
often
High performing High earning
folks sit down and have this
conversation as a math problem
honey we make this much money we got to
make a budget
well I have one I have an Excel sheet I
can show you I know you do yeah it's
useful here's what I'm telling you
there's a different conversation when
you sit down with your wife and you hold
their hands and you say honey
I can't breathe
I'm so scared we make way too much money
I'm working so hard
and I feel like you and I are full of
pulling further and further and further
apart
and I love you too much to be frustrated
at you all the time because I know
that's hard to live with
and I love you too much for us to
pretend that we're all joyful and happy
once a year at Christmas and we try to
throw money at our friends and family
instead of being a warm safe place for
them to come land
would you build something different with
me that's a different conversation than
honey look at my spreadsheet look at
this if you just would do this then we
could get out of this crap one of those
she's gonna go to her defense and that
defense is probably way older than you
and that's probably been there since she
was a little kid and then you go to your
defense because she starts bombing you
back and it's different when you take
ownership and say I want my wife and I
want a family that I want to unificate a
unified front here I want a unified
vision of what we're going to do and I'm
scared to death I'm gonna lose you the
irony is is that you think by
acquiescing you're creating peace
and you're not
that's the irony the fire is burning in
the basement and it is hot
it's coals you know and because you you
this is It's eating you up and she can
feel that on you and then she goes about
solving that feeling with the way that
her body's been solving those feelings
for her whole life spending spending and
trying to make people feel good about
themselves and showing people how great
she's doing
and that's different than y'all two
building a life together yeah
yeah and if you guys can't sit down work
that through and start to say we need to
develop a new vision for our future a
different plan
other than just spinning our Wheels
feeling like a rat in a wheel I'm scared
I can't do this this is killing me I
cannot live in a situation where I make
a quarter million dollars a year and we
have nothing that is just absurd to me
my brain can't do it anymore my mind
can't do it my psyche my spirit can't do
it anymore so we have got to develop
some plan for the future that we're both
willing to work towards and I want to do
that with you let's start fresh a fresh
a reset not we've got to get on a budget
sometimes but that will lead you by the
way to a budget and it's not a
spreadsheet budget it's an every dollar
budget but it'll lead you to the two of
you working together to implement the
plan that you have agreed to together
that both of you had to vote in
I love starting those conversations with
I'm sorry I'm sorry I've tried to
control you the way I know to control a
problem I've tried to solve you I've
tried to fix you I'm sorry
let me tell you the truth I'm scared to
death and there's a different there's a
different approach there someone can
enter into your space that way instead
of uh having to swing back at you it's
tough
hope that works for you brother and then
pay that truck off in the next 20
minutes
um or a couple months and or sell it one
of the two that's um because it's you
know you went and bought a truck while
she went and bought Christmas thank you
yeah you showed her man I think you
spent more so um there you go and the
850 is coming in whether you have a
truck payment or not so that doesn't
justify it our question of the day is
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services most American homes have
dozens of appliances and chances are at
any given time something wrong with at
least one of them Mr Appliance a
neighborly brand offers expert appliance
service on your schedule visit
neighborly.com today to find Home
Service Experts including Mr Appliance
in your area today's question comes from
Jane in Florida I pay the bills for my
elderly father he has a bad habit of
going to the ATM to withdraw money
several times a week A lot of times it
leaves me with a balance too low to pay
his bills I've had numerous talks
threatened to stop helping etc
etc he apologizes and Promises to do
better then in a few weeks he's right
back to the same situation I don't want
to be disrespectful to him but is it
real it's really stressing me out what
do you recommend I do
I'm not going to help you with your
bills anymore unless you give me your
ATM card
I'm unable to help anymore unless you
give me your ATM card I can't I can't
participate yeah you you're making this
too hard
you're sabotaging everything I'm trying
to do to help you I'm trying to love you
and you're clearly you're telling me
very clearly you don't want my love and
support and help yeah so if you want to
give me the ATM card I'll keep doing it
if you don't then I won't yeah that's
why I still love you but I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna spend all of my time
resenting how you're living your life
and then you come to me asking for help
I don't want to resent you you're my dad
I want to love you so I'm either going
to turn this over to you or you can hand
me your ATM card yeah that's easy yeah I
can fix that and it's not a flax and
it's not it's not showing your muscles
it's just saying hey I'm choosing to not
do this anymore I can't yeah this is
this is an absurd dog chasing its tails
keep pulling you out of the pool and you
just keep jumping in if you want to stay
in there ah man it's tough I keep
getting you out of the road and you keep
running back out there yeah it's tough
yeah it's
um it's it well it's um
it's frustrating because a is someone
you love and B they're hurting
themselves and
um and see it's so cyclical yeah it's a
it's circular here it's a dance the
whole thing is circular it's ridiculous
yeah Stop Dancing bad Florida two-step
there you go this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsay
personality number one best-selling
often host of the Dr John baloney show
is my co-host today this hour we're
going to be talking about one of my
favorite subjects baby steps
millionaires people who have become
millionaires we want to talk to real
millionaires you see when I started
doing this Radio Show in 1992
over 30 years ago
I had this idea and I still do
that if we taught gods and grandmas ways
of handling money
live on less than you make
have a written plan
get out of debt and stay out of debt
steadily invest and Save
and be outrageously generous
if you do those five things consistently
in your life that over a period of time
you would become wealthy
it's a mathematical fact number one but
number two it's just the fastest right
way to become wealthy and now here I sit
30 plus years later and there's lots of
you have become millionaires doing this
stuff lots of you
and if you did it following the baby
steps we call you a baby steps
millionaire you do not have to be a baby
steps millionaire to be on this show
today but you do need to be a
millionaire and for some of you that are
new to this let me help you with this a
millionaire is an accounting term
it's not a Feeling
I don't feel like I have much it doesn't
matter what you feel couldn't care less
about your feelings this is not a
feelings show that's John's show
uh it is no one should have that much
money well this is not a moral construct
it's not a discussion of wealth
inequality although I can go there if
you want me to
um it's not any of that a millionaire is
simply an accounting term it's your net
worth well he's a net worth millionaire
that's the only kind of millionaire
there is it's a redundant statement okay
your net worth is your what you own
minus what you owe assets minus
liabilities when that equals a million
dollars
regardless of what the assets are
regardless of what the liabilities are
when assets minus liabilities own versus
o equals a million dollars or a
millionaire
and it's not as much money as it used to
be
it might not be enough to do some of the
things you want to do but it's more than
most people have
there's about 17 millionaires 17 million
millionaires in North America
so they're out there they're all around
us I meet them every day when I'm doing
the show every single day when I take a
break during this show at a commercial
break I walk outside and someone comes
up to get their picture taken with me I
sign a book or two and I always meet at
least one millionaire
every day and they came by to say hey
this is the place this is where I
learned all this stuff this is how it's
almost like a a visit to uh a shrine
that caused them to be able to do it now
obviously we didn't do it we didn't give
them any money we just said you could do
it we've made you believe you could do
it and we showed you how and what the
steps are and the Tactical moves with
money but there's no magic pill here
and here's the truth
it can be done and we're going to prove
it by talking to real millionaires today
Blake is with us in Nashville Blake
what's your net worth
my net worth is like five to six million
dollars good for you okay give me a
little breakdown by category on that
um I've got a couple million dollars in
stocks slash mutual funds uh a million
dollars and uh some uh a real estate
property uh in an evaluation of uh a
couple businesses is between you know
one to three million dollars okay all
right in a business Oh no I got about a
hundred thousand cash yeah so how old
are you
I am 32 actually be 33 tomorrow wow
happy birthday and how much of this 5
million did you inherit
uh zero the only thing I inherited is a
common sense and financial sense so
that's uh that's one thing I've
inherited but no dude five million at 33
is Pretty stinking impressive from zero
yes sir thank you so what has been your
best year income and your worst year
income since you've been working the
last 13 years or so
starting off at you know no income in 13
years ago but my highest year would
probably be last year and did right at
uh seven figures right at a million and
then this year we're looking at uh doing
about 60 to 70k a month okay and we're
talking about profit here taxable income
yes sir way to go man what kind of a
business have you got
actually it's a a martial arts school I
do own some properties too but um I grew
up doing martial arts and when I was 19
uh opened uh open to school and uh
that's been the rest is history so it's
it's been very fortunate to be able to
take a passion and make a career you
know not only change my life but those
around me as well very cool you have a
four-year degree
yes I have a degree in business finance
what was your GPA in 2012. um
gosh probably
3.6 2.7 something like that okay so you
would say I think if I'm listening to
your story correctly that the way you
became a millionaire was you were very
successful in business
he's tried to learn from other people's
experience and wisdom and try not to
duplicate some of their mistakes and and
uh yeah it's just a lot of good
decisions and planning things out and I
lived with my parents so I was about 26
so you have to pay everything off and
make sure that uh you know I was
financially set
I spent some time doing martial arts
myself not nearly with a lifelong
commitment you've made how much of that
slow and steady and just discipline and
doing the same things over and over
again how much of that have you used in
the business world because it sounds
like you've like if I look back you've
moved really quickly to gain this much
net worth but at the same time it sounds
like you've just been pretty methodical
and pretty wise about your next steps
yeah I think that uh you know martial
arts the self-discipline that comes with
martial arts you know I started when I
was eight years old and I think that
that's one that I learned from Matt uh
it kind of bled over into uh my uh being
able to make good financial decisions
and you know I tell my students before
you can learn to do something you have
to learn to do nothing and uh you know
just take your time and think and plan
things out instead of making you know
irrational decisions based on emotion
wow okay there's a 19 year old version
of you out there what do you telling the
secret is
um I think the the first thing is being
able to find a mentor uh someone that
you that you look up to whether it's you
know you're based on your financial uh
what you know goals financially or
whether it's a relationship or safe and
then follow them listen to them and then
part two like we just touched on is
being able to have this help discipline
to follow through with it and do it you
know consistently
dude you're a stud man you're a hero
well done that's absolutely amazing
starting from nothing and uh five
million dollars at 33 years old happy
birthday wow leave your contact
information with Christian on the phone
there because I've been looking for a
school for my two kids and you're
exactly the kind of man that I want my
kids learning from so leave your leave
your school info uh I'm you're you just
knock my socks off my man very cool good
stuff man good stuff this is a baby
steps millionaires theme hour on the
Ramsay show
hahaha
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a baby steps Millionaire's theme
hour Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five as we take questions from only
millionaires actually we don't want to
take questions we're actually going to
give you the questions we're going to
interview you and find out how you got
here
the misnomer is that
millionaires can't happen in America
today unless you're a movie star or a
sports figure or a music icon of some
kind and the truth is among people that
have a million dollar net worth are
greater those three categories put
together account two less than one
percent of the millionaires hey you
wrote about a thing in the baby steps
millionaires that
it was a light bulb moment for me I
would love for you to talk about a
little bit you have a section called
millionaires are not billionaires and I
thought that was an instructive
conversation to have well yeah it's it's
um I think sometimes when because the
the whole thing on millionaire became a
thing in the 20s
because a millionaire then was a lot of
money that's a billionaire in the 1920s
probably a billionaire yeah and so it
was like the game Monopoly was developed
about that time right and so everything
is around this idea of acquiring and
building a net worth of a million
dollars because that was rich those
became the definition of rich
and Easy Street you're gonna be on Easy
Street and so then but what has happened
is over the years then the people think
it's not attainable to become a
millionaire which is a really good place
to be as a minimum starting point going
into your retirement it's not necessary
that you're there to live but you you
know that that sets you up for a pretty
strong golden years it does not set you
up for opulence okay and so like for
instance no millionaires almost no
millionaires on a jet
almost no millionaires own a four
hundred thousand dollar Lamborghini or
seven cars okay almost no millionaires
have uh a house uh at the beach a house
in the mountains and a house that is a
house most of them have one house
that's it so it's a it's a that's
instructive for me because when I think
I could never have a no because that's
not the goal well it's not the first
goal you could get there but a bit see a
billion is a thousand million
when you think about that it's a
thousand times more than a millionaire
well yeah they've got a chat yeah
they've got seven cars and yeah they got
four houses but they got a thousand
times more money that's it's still a uh
it's still five percent of their net
worth right exactly exactly but I mean
it's a it's so but what I the reason I
want to point that out is in the book
and when we're talking about it is not
that a billion is bad and a million is
good that's not the point or that you
but but if you think of I'll never have
enough money to have a jet a house three
houses and seven cars then you're not
thinking about a million dollars you're
thinking about a billion dollars and so
yeah that is there are a lot fewer of
those right you know when I started this
show only 300 of the 400 Forbes 400
wealthiest people were billionaires even
now a hundred percent of them are
billionaires and it requires prob you
know quite a several billion to even be
on that list you know and so but that's
you know the the number of billionaires
there are in America whoa way less than
millionaires so it's okay okay to be a
billionaire if you want to call me and
tell me how you got to be a billionaire
oh by the way you're not going to become
a billionaire mathematically with your
401k right and you're paid for a house
but you will become a millionaire with
those two things
uh which is the first step you know the
first one to five million to hit there
so uh you know but but you don't talk
the uh of the people on the force 400
the billionaires uh 67 of them are first
generation they did not inherit their
money
two out of three that's that's a bunch I
mean so that says it can still be done
but uh like 90 uh not us I think all of
them I'll have to go back and look I
looked at one time it may be one or two
that inherited money of the ones that
made it the started from nothing all of
them owned and ran big businesses his
business yeah lightning struck yeah they
you know Michael Dell Dell computers
right Bill Gates Microsoft right Apple
uh you know you go through and you look
at the tech world you go through and
look at um uh uh uh you know uh Elon
Kathy family Chick-fil-A okay Elon Musk
um you know those Elon and uh uh Buffett
are the two number number one number two
in Bezos you know but Bezos started his
Elon started his for nothing yeah they
both came from nothing and so but that's
but but don't confuse those two if uh it
because it can lead you to losing hope
that it can be done because the
millionaire is very attainable
billionaire you gotta you gotta run a
business probably not you got to run a
big business it can be done but you're
not gonna do that with your 401k not
mathematically no you can't put enough
in there to get there it's that simple
Margaret is with us in Washington DC
Margaret your net worth uh 5.6 million
and I feel like I'm slow to I feel like
I'm slow to the dance based on that last
caller because he's 32 and I'm 57. we're
all slow to the dance after that last
caller I'll just tell you so you're 57
all right give me a little breakdown on
that uh 5.6 million sure it our home
um we beach home a commercial office
space small commercial office space is
worthwhile about three point uh 3.1 3.2
okay and the remaining amount in our
401ks IRAs annuity liquid assets
um and just a whole so another 2.5 of
that correct okay all right can you be
proud of me I spoke to you last December
and you told me you're I was crazy that
I kept a balance on my beach house
mortgage because I had so much in cash
and today after talking to Don I went to
the bank and I paid off the remaining
Beach but beach house all right you
can't come on the air again without that
thing paid off
you made me go back in debt because I
bought your book today
well if you're going to go back in debt
buy 100 of them then yeah
all right how much of this 5.6 did you
inherit zero all right and your best
year working income your worst year
working income
okay and what's your careers
turning and
um yeah so I've always been in business
for myself and I always say I have a
great boss okay cool well obviously he
has a law degree what's your degree
um my undergrad was education in Spanish
I was going to be a Spanish teacher and
then I got into the computer field and
then at age 50 I got my masters in
business MBA no actually I have a love
for nutrition and food studies and
wanted to become a nutritionist but then
I found out there's no money in it so I
stuck with my business all right but I
still do nutrition on the side love it
okay and what was your GPA
um as a masters it was 4.0
um undergrad I didn't really that was
terrible like 3.3 I should have known
that's awful I can't believe you did
that
okay oh man I've got I've got two hard
questions for you um the first one is
how much of that did you steal
zero all right all right I thought y'all
were all crooked yeah no no none at all
all right the second one is how many
books do you read a month
you know I'm ashamed because I I I don't
I read probably two a year because by
the time my kids I mean my son just
graduated from college my daughter's in
college and I'm exhausted I still opened
the books and I fall asleep I've been
I've been there last few months hey so
that makes that makes me even more
grateful that you read one to two books
a year and you bought his book you
bought mine that makes my heart full
thank you and I have your other book as
well and I do I do I am reading
intentional living by John Maxwell
um and uh so I I just don't read enough
I'm embarrassed don't be embarrassed you
should read anything John Maxwell writes
he's awesome yeah we love John you're
doing great yeah yeah we're really
enjoying it my book will for sure put
you to sleep so good I have to tell you
can I tell you something really
I told Donna
sure I made a stupid
and I got out of college I had a Mazda
RX7 beautiful California ocean blue me
and my husband at the time my ex-husband
and we couldn't afford the tires they
were going to be over a thousand dollars
to put new tires on so I thought it was
a really Savvy business business person
I said let's go to the Honda dealership
and let's lease the car for 200 a month
and uh we'll save ourselves eight
hundred dollars
and then you still ended up with 5.6
million by 57. you overcome the thousand
dollar Tire deal well done awesome way
to go Margaret good talking to you this
is a baby steps Millionaire's theme hour
on the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today it's a baby steps
millionaires theme hour anybody that has
a net worth of a million dollars you're
welcome to call in we want to know how
much you got how you did it so that
other people can learn from you learn
what we call in business best practices
how'd you do it so we can do it
Zach is with us in Salt Lake City Zach
what's your net worth
hi Dave and John it's uh 1.8 million
somewhere on there excellent and give me
a little breakdown by category
so paid off house it's around a million
dollars
Ira set IRA and a brokerage account
invested in mutual funds around 450 000.
I've got a CD with 200 000 in it and
then our you know high yield savings
with 150 000 that way to go how old are
you
37. all right very good and how much of
this did you inherit
zero
zero all right I love it very good cool
cool and your income your best year and
your worst year
it was around 650 000. wow and uh worst
year was around fifty thousand okay cool
what do you do for a living
yeah I I run a sales team for a Solar
Company
wow okay cool Euphoria degree
no degree I went for three years and and
uh found out sales is my calling and and
so I I never finished but but 650 000
lighter you figured it out huh
I guess so yeah
way to go man very very cool all right
what do you tell the younger version of
you is it still possible today to become
a millionaire starting from nothing like
you did
absolutely in fact I think it's it's
probably easier today than ever there's
a lot of good a lot of good
opportunities out there and uh
uh you know I I think that I wish I'd
have known years ago I called in to the
show last year
and um I was actually a net worth
millionaire last year before I started
following your plan and I called in and
he gave me some encouragement to go
ahead and pay off my house and and
everything so I wish that I'd have
started younger I always lived under my
means but I wish I started following you
know avoiding debt and and investing
younger and one one thing that I do want
to say is is uh you know there's a lot
of people that you know disagree I guess
with paying off a mortgage early they
say hey you should keep that money you
know keep the mortgage and invest the
money or whatever and I I get their
argument but the thing that I really
like about what you teach is once you
have that mortgage paid off
um it's a lot easier to invest into
retirement and other things I'm
investing a lot of money right now every
month on on autopilot and I if I would
have had a mortgage or car payments I
wouldn't be doing those Investments and
that's probably the best argument I've
heard from from Ramsey on on that yeah
you know my contention also is and ask
you about this because it's interesting
to me
um is that when you're running a
business a small business like you are
um uh that you make different decisions
when you have zero debt at home
absolutely I'm more confident in the
decisions I make here at Ramsey because
I don't have to worry about the home
front
I agree yep and therefore I think I
think I end up making more money here
because of that
I think I agree I think I may agree
there's no desperation decisions
it's a lot easier to make a sell when
you don't have to make the deal yeah I
agree yeah because uh broke sales people
smell bad
they do and you can also break up with
those customers that are just driving
you mad
um you could say you know I'm gonna move
on because I don't I don't need this I
don't have to have this so that my
family can eat
and hey so why we got you you got a lot
of money in CDs in a savings account are
you saving for something big Yeah Yeah
we actually have a family friend that
he's developing some land up here
um about a mile or two from my house it
should be ready in the next year so
that's why I've been piling when it
comes available I want to I want to buy
a lot with cash good news deloney
fantastic hey and one more thing so um
you're a good case study for me I'm
always telling folks listen I get the if
you're one of those folks who bought a
house at 2.9 I get the math problem
there it's an excellent math problem in
your favor especially when you look
historically
you had that you had a house on the
front end of this and then you're a
millionaire and then you thought I'm
just gonna pay this thing off
what kind of piece do you have in your
house
do you feel different tell me if I'm
crazy because I don't mind being wrong
in fact I'm wrong a lot but is it does
it feel different it's my it's yours
it feels a lot different what Dave
always says about you know walking
barefoot in the grass it just feels
different
you don't really know that feeling until
you go ahead and pay off the house and
so I I'll never go into debt again and a
lot of my friends kind of laugh at that
and they think oh you know when you
build a house you will and I said no
I'll uh I'm gonna save up and and maybe
go a little bit slower but it's silly to
me to think that I had a mortgage and
and car payments before now that you're
out of it I don't want to ever want to
go back and and the feeling is really
really good yeah when it goes back I'm
proud of you man yeah you're a stud man
you're a hero way to go very proud of
you good work Ann is with us in Columbus
Ohio and your net worth
just at 2.5 million love it okay and uh
how old are you
I'm 46 my husband is 52. all right very
cool give me a little breakdown by
category on the two and a half million
it's 1.7 in retirement 600 in our paid
off home a hundred thousand dollars in
cash and another 100 in other
miscellaneous Investments very good 29s
and perfect match well done how much of
this did you inherit
well a few years ago many years ago I
got four thousand dollars when my
grandmother passed away okay so it's
safe to say you are not a millionaire
because of an inheritance
no but I do have good parents yeah I
didn't say that hey I just I want you to
know if you watch us on YouTube live I
just laughed but not at your
Grandmother's passing you set this up
and I thought you were gonna say I got a
million dollars but you said I got four
thousand bucks yeah so what's your best
year working income since you've been
working in your worst year
well our worst year was back during the
beginning of the stay-at-home mom years
and it was about 70 000 and our best
year will probably be this year where it
should be around 440
000. wow but
um it's only been like that the last so
many years since we're empty nesters so
most of those years were you know under
a hundred thousand 100 to 150 we went
back and looked and um where we are
today especially from the retirement
front is based on what we did during
those years where we didn't make a lot
of money it's much less based on what we
do today
yeah so what do you what do you do for a
living and what's your husband do what's
your careers
um we're both mechanical engineers by
degree I work in marketing and he works
in project management
okay and I assume you have engineering
degrees both of you
yes okay and your um
GPA
uh well so remember the engineer it was
a three point for me because that's what
I needed to keep my scholarship or my
parents were making me pay for school
and it was 2.7 for my husband's
undergrad and he actually got accepted
into a master's program conditionally
because they were concerned about his
2.7 GPA but he worked full time all the
way through college yeah wow you guys
are incredible what's your advice to the
younger version of you listening
be very intentional about who you marry
somebody with shared values shared goals
somebody who's hard working take FPU
early
taking Financial Peace University we
didn't take it till 2013 and it was
rocket fuel we had a lot of the the
basics in place but that's really what
brought everything together wow thanks
for the ad that was awesome
it's just amazing very well done thank
you and we appreciate you you're amazing
I'm so proud of you guys way to go ero
this is a baby steps Millionaire's theme
hour on the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
Philippians 4 12 I know what it is to be
in need and I know what it is to have
plenty I have learned the secret of
being content in any and every situation
whether well-fed or hungry whether
living in plenty or in want
David Lee Roth said money can't buy you
happiness but it can buy you a big yacht
a yacht big enough to pull up alongside
it
oh my goodness well done oh Wayne is in
Chattanooga Wayne your net worth
hey uh Dave thanks for taking my call
um
3.4 million good for you all right how
old are you give or take give or take a
month you know okay it works how old are
you I'm 62. 62. all right and give me a
little break give me a little breakdown
on the 3.4 million
all right
all right so I will say let's say nine
years ago I had about a million dollars
day
um and since that time uh and and that
million dollars was you know
mostly in traditional 401K uh so it's
you know taxable
um and
since that time I've made a few uh real
estate Investments
um and have basically in that nine years
changed that million
two over three million dollars good for
you through multiple some of it being
um residential and then uh you know
um one of those Investments was a
commercial investment
so
um
yeah that's kind of where it's ended up
um I I'm debt free
my home's worth approximately 425
000.
um and that's kind of where I'm at good
for you well done yeah okay yeah all
right and what was your how much of this
did you inherit
well
that's a funny story uh my father passed
away when I was very young I inherited
uh seven thousand dollars
um and as and I was a teenager uh at
that point I I bought a car for a truck
for 3 500 bucks so left me with 3 500
dollars and so I decided my grandfather
was a uh he invested and I didn't know
anything about it but what I did know is
I knew that it it it really my
grandfather was he ended up very wealthy
so
um I wanted to kind of Follow that path
so I went to the bank and the banker
said to me he says uh yeah you know I
had 3 500 said just put it in your
savings account I said well I'm not
really I don't really want to do that
and uh so ultimately I've put in 30 or
put in 500 into a savings account
and then I had three thousand dollars
left and and through the help of my
grandfather and I was 17 years old at
the time uh helped me invest that into a
mutual fund
um which was a Fidelity Magellan fund
I'm sure you're familiar with that yeah
what's it worth today
uh hundreds of thousands no dollars I
never I never touched it uh that's
incredible and it uh
and I think for the younger the younger
generation to understand what investing
is about I had to go to a facility
we had to go somewhere make an
appointment in order for me to invest
that three three thousand dollars uh and
it was there was a fee attached to it it
was it was a process I mean today I
could do that in 60 seconds you know uh
and I and I believe today
Building Wealth is so much easier than
it was when you and I were growing up
you're right you're right and and so is
destroying it both are easier it's so
just enjoying it it absolutely is
um but I think I think it's it's it's so
much easier today
if I if I were myself back then
planet today it'd be so much easier I'd
be work
tens of millions of dollars more I mean
there's no question there's no question
about it if I knew then what I know now
wow absolutely way to go Wayne proud of
you man excellent job Dave I I'm just
struck this is a small sample size
but everyone we've talked to today has
been generating wealth significantly
several of our callers said they've had
their best years this year or last year
recently
and every shred of news I get from every
angle of my life is how the economy's
falling apart there's no way to get
ahead everybody everything's awful it's
all coming down
and all the calls we took today people
are saying well it's the time and
apparently someone uh decided not to
participate in the recession High
interest rates and high we can't do it
with they're just they just are one
guy's a Salesman somebody else is a
Salesman somebody else is a
it's two sales people an attorney a
martial arts uh owner two mechanical
engineers
um best year ever best year ever best
year ever yeah yeah this year this year
despite the inflation despite nobody
spending any more than five million 5.6
million 1.8 million 2.5 million 3.4
million no one inherited anything
appreciably I mean that was nothing
substantial that made them a millionaire
and so the idea that all millionaires
are inherited money 79 of millionaires
in our study inherited zero another five
percent inherited a small amount like
these fourth aisles four thousand seven
thousand dollars but not enough to make
you a millionaire and another five
percent inherited substantial money
after they were already millionaires so
5 and 5 and 79 is 89 so that will help
tell you that nine out of ten of
America's millionaires are first
generation Rich did it without an
inheritance so when these left-wing nut
jobs tell you that it's all over and the
only thing that's going to work for you
is Karl Marx because their college
professor who's a communist told them
that uh and then they tell you that it's
impossible to get ahead in America I'm
telling you the actual data says 9 out
of 10 millionaires are first generation
rich
I'd say it's such it's so counter
counterintuitive it's so counter
narrative both counter narrative yeah
counterintuitive counter narrative at
the macro level at the you just can't
get ahead anymore and then at the micro
level
it's all coming down it's all coming
down it's all coming down it's just not
yeah it might be but it doesn't look I
mean everybody's having the best year of
their life man it's 100 100 a month
invested from age 25 to age 65 at 12 in
a good mutual fund and the stock market
is average 11.6
for 80 years okay but so you know it 100
a month invested from H25 days 65 is one
million 176 thousand dollars
a hundred dollars
that's with no match
that that's with you know no magic
Tick-Tock mirrors to buy nothing down
real estate that you can't afford or
shirts t-shirts on four on four payments
[Laughter]
true yeah there's no payments involved
in that uh but people can't find a
hundred dollars you know and uh and the
reason is it got a 750 truck payment
and the reason is I got a student loan
that during the last three years when
there's been no interest they paid
nothing on it and come Sunday
Bloody Sunday
here we go man man uh I mean it's uh
this coming Sunday is the when the
student loans start back October one
baby it's here life is real so we're
going to send a team to uh Washington
D.C
yeah and do some man on the street stuff
Monday
because that's uh when the student loans
have started back the government might
also shut down by then because the
children in the sandbox throwing crayons
at each other
good gosh Billy kick sand in my eyes
he's a republican I don't like Dan he's
a Democrat it's mice mice my sand castle
I want to put two billion dollars in for
uh Rat research in into the budget we
keep voting for these and if you don't
do that then we're going to shut down
the government you know so you know what
it would be kind of cool if they solve
some of these problems with dodgeball
you voted him in I voted immense our
freaking fault we we do this to
ourselves man I don't know one person
that's like man bang-up job bang-up job
yeah anybody's doing yeah I think you
guys are just amazing the efficiency by
which you govern and did you see that
thing that uh Warren Buffett said it's
like amazing but he said oh I could
solve the deficit tomorrow yep you're
all fired yeah well or you don't you get
zero pay until you get the budget
balanced oh by the way I saw that
um all the federal employees will lose
their paychecks when they shut the
government down but not the uh Congress
congress not the Congress nope nope uh
we vote ourselves an exemption because
we're incompetent that puts this hour
the Rams are showing the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's what walk daily with the Prince
of Peace Christ Jesus
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]